so it's known for being one of the
smelliest fruits and I can attest that
it is also it has a delightful custard
like filling go ahead let's say I lean
in there get it get a nice whip oh gosh
if you could liken this smell to
anything what would you say it smells
like gasoline all right guys go ahead
try that Varian it looks like old
cauliflower it looks like I'm doing a
lab the section it really does smell
like gasoline like it smells like a
topia from Disneyland there's a part of
Disneyland that smells like this what
part do I eat whatever smells the worst
that's what you eat
yeah the goopy stuff that was a huge
body that's one of the good things about
being older you can't taste too much
looks like an embryo
I feel like this looks like a fetus oh
my god hey embryo fetus all the stages
and miracle of life here guys how you
feeling Jose it went down yes what's it
taste like fish it's fish what you want
sweet to taste like how does it behave
it doesn't behave what if it doesn't
see you in it how do you feel I don't
know you kind of look like you like it
it does like it first taste is awful
second taste is not so bad
oh yes for a third Jose you really went
for it there do you want to spit it into
my hand no I don't want to spit it into
your head who say you're crying you know
this stuff is expensive in the grocery
store yeah he's just eating it because
he knows it's be worth a lot of money
don't don't toy with Armas Jose you know
you hate it
Jose you've almost bounded twice your
hair is too beautiful about it
go on you can spit it into my hand
it's okay it's okay okay okay
it's okay it's okay it's okay I'm gonna
put it on this cardboard it's a good to
clipboard you know what I'll tell you
right now the texture of it is better
when it's been chewed it's already so
bad